si la violence était un animal serait un
pic du si la violence est une maladie à
se ré le sida si la violence un exercice
de poésie dans une cave de la banlieue
parisienne de calme pas un texte
construit au hasard mais dément que les
enfants ont choisi pour décrire la
violence et qui traduit la vente ou le
mal de ville de leur quartier
les enfants sont vraiment fait la
réalité parce que quand on a tout de
suite commencé particulaire la violence
était un pays riche entendu ce serait
l'algérie
si la violence était à l'animal c'est le
pic du jour c'est vraiment les éléments
qui entourent les enfants tous les jours
jusqu'à un exercice de style ce travail
et surtout une leçon dans une école
traumatisés pourquoi nous avons fils
saccagé c'est le mot et par trois fois
un mois plus tôt dans ce quartier dit
sensible pour la première fois on s'est
attaqué à l'école et surprise les
coupables rapidement identifiés sont des
enfants de 9 à 13 ans
dans l'urgence le ministre venu
constater les dégâts à nommer un
instituteur directeur dans cette école
qui n'en avait plus les actes de
violence jusqu'ici c'était surtout
derrière cette porte qui s'éteint
l'école du collège
en primaire les institutrices doit
chanter certaines autorités pour
maintenir le calme dans son là on la
ressent plutôt au niveau des francos
savoir bond et a juré que les entrants
tendance est bien problème est que suite
à sa victime et colère la violence
physique elle vient souvent à
saint-lambert balle mais elle est quand
même une violence latente que les
enseignants des rencontres et en évitant
des règles de vie pas toujours faciles à
mettre en pratique
il est gros
c'est aussi pour cette école faire
cohabiter des enfants de cultures
différentes se leva scène et de vous
devez tenir ses comptoirs
pour ne pas traumatiser plus l'événement
et provoqué rots et d'autres dates les
plus violents les élèves impliqués dans
le saccage de l'école n'ont pas été
exclus les enseignants les ont
temporairement changé le club